bonjour à tous sur un vide est
aujourd'hui je m'appelle elodie et comme
vous avez pu le voir par rapport aux un
petit peu au titre je vais être un petit
peu orthez donc c'est un peu à ce moment
là où vous allez vous dire mais qu'est
ce qui se passe ce qu'elle est un peu
arrogante et trop sûre d'elle qui est
elle en fait pour se dire que ce qu'elle
va faire d'être parfait et c'est ok
parce que je pense que ça vous déjà ça
vous est déjà aussi arrivé de vous de
porter des jugements sur vous même de
vous sentir trop ou pas assez de porter
de jugement sur votre corps votre vie
jamais trop toujours jamais trop est
toujours pas assez comme ceux tedx vous
êtes parfaitement à l'endroit où vous
devez être en ce moment avec la vie que
vous devez que vous que vous devez avoir
en ce moment et entre nous il était
impossible pour moi aujourd'hui de la
nana hyper confiante que je rêve d'être
de tout vous raconter et de tout vous
dire
dans un discours d'une vingtaine de
minutes et sur cette expérience qu'on
pourrait juger imparfaite
vous allez également me juger et ce sera
ok et cette expérience finalement elle
sera parfaite pour vous pour moi parce
que les mots qui sortiront est ce que
vous retiendrez sont parfaits pour donc
pour commencer ce parfait tedx je vais
vous raconter une histoire
imaginez un porteur d'eau indien qui à
l'extrémité d'une pièce de bois portes
de jaar lune déjà réparé fait belle et
brillante l'autre jarrah un éclat et
alors que l'aja par cette arrivée à
assurer sa mission du début à la fin
sans faille et sans perdre de l'eau la
jab imparfaite
elle ne réussissait qu'apporter la
moitié de sa cargaison dos alors l'aja
parfaite et srd elle est là jardin
parfaite au bout de deux ans de ça elle
considérait finalement commettre un
échec permanent elle dit au porteur
d'eau je suis désolé je te prie de
m'excuser
pourquoi lui répondit le porteur d'eau à
cause de moi à cause de mon
imperfections tu ne vois pas tout le
travail que tu fais tu ne rigole pas le
fruit de tes efforts et le porteur d'eau
lui dit alors sur le chemin du retour je
voudrais que tu regardes les fleurs sur
le chemin et c'est ce que fit la jarre
imparfaite en remontant à la maison je m
elle regarda les magnifiques fleurs qui
était sur le chemin et ça lui mis du
baume au coeur
pourtant elle se sentait toujours aussi
mal et c'est alors que le porteur d'eau
lui dit j'ai toujours su que tu perdais
de l'eau j'ai semé des graines et j'en
ai tiré profit sans toi jamais je
n'aurais pu ramener des fleurs aussi
belle aussi fraîche sur la table du
maître
et si je vous disais que nous sommes
tous déjà cassé et que nos imperfections
sont en réalité des forces créatrices
tellement
que sans ces imperfections beaucoup de
projets d'associations d'entreprises
n'aurait jamais pu voir le jour alors
comment finalement transformé ses
imperfections super pouvoirs pour
réaliser quelque chose d'extraordinaire
lorsqu'on veut réaliser un projet
réalisé un rêve mettre en place quelque
chose nous devons faire face à troyes
type d'image celle que nous avons de la
société celle que nous avons de
l'environnement et celle que nous avons
de nous mêmes
je suis une femme je suis musulmane et
en plus j'ai décidé de porter le hijab
et en plus j'avais des difficultés en
maths et en plus je suis jeune maman et
en plus j'avais pas forcément le profil
de la business woman un peu trop
bisounours pour se vendre dès que j'ai
porter le hijab
j'étais un peu fichiers j'étais passé de
la femme ambitieuse et libre à la femme
soumise discrète et sans voix toujours
selon la société que notre jeu je me
souviens lors d'une présentation
d'entreprise une gentille dame m'a dit
avant de partir en plein milieu mais a
franchi c'est vous ou encore de ce
commentaire sur les réseaux sociaux
ce foulard maximise lorsque j'ai voulu
donner ma première conférence
alors oui il a des portes que la société
française en tout cas me ferme
adieu les concours de professeurs adieu
les postes à hautes responsabilités dans
les grandes entreprises
parce qu'en fait ce qu'on venait de me
dire c'était soit et croyante mais
surtout tulle affiche surtout pas
surtout pas ta croyances et tout ira
bien pour toi sois tu reste bien à ta
place et tu corresponds pas aux clichés
qui va avec
sauf que moi j'avais toujours des grands
rêves
j'étais toujours la même toujours la
même ambition
et j'ai finalement dû composer avec tout
ça inventer mes propres règles mes
propres normes et me dépasser mon hijab
aujourd'hui aux yeux de la société
cette tête éventuellement vos kilos en
trop ou en moins votre timidité ou votre
sueur confiance en vous ça peut être
aussi tous les traits de caractère
finalement quand juste toujours être au
passé pour ce monde et ce n'est pas tout
ça c'était la partie la plus facile à
passer parce qu'on a un sacré bagage en
fait vous et moi on part avec ce qu'on
appelle des croyances donc ses croyances
héritées de notre environnement de notre
expérience de comment on agrandit ses
croyances façonnent notre regard sur le
monde et en fonction de ses croyances
nous n'agissons pas de la même façon
pour illustrer le tout je vais me
prendre comme exemple
depuis petit j'ai grandi dans un
environnement où j'ai toujours été
comparé ce que je faisais n'était jamais
bien ou toujours décevant et finalement
ça fait de moi une adulte toujours à
l'affût de ce que les autres peuvent
penser toujours à 30 en train de se
comparer à droite et à gauche et de se
dire ce n'est jamais très bien tu peux
faire plus tu peux faire mieux
finalement lorsqu'on m'a dit à partir de
ces croyances là lorsqu'on m'a dit mais
avoir un enfant et ouvrir une entreprise
six mois plus tard c'est fou quand même
non écoutez je n'ai jamais été aussi
forte que depuis que j'ai eu mon fils
lorsqu'on m'a dit ouvrir une entreprise
tournée vers l'humain en feu en faisant
du marketing
il n'y a pas quelque chose qui cloche
non ce sont vos croyances
mais malgré tout il a eu un moment où
j'ai rongé j'ai intégré ces croyances
comme étant les miennes et j'ai fini par
revoir les ambitions à la baisse donc
j'ai commencé à faire n'importe quoi
professionnellement parce qu'il fallait
que ma famille soit en sécurité
j'ai voulu faire un truc qui paye et
puis c'est tout un truc dénué de sens et
vous savez quoi
ça n'a pas marché je suis parti au bout
d'un an de cette entreprise
les derniers mois ont vraiment été très
difficile parce que je pleurais le tous
les soirs en rentrant et je me levais
tous les matins en retard je me sentais
mal vraiment mal d'y aller donc après
cette expérience professionnelle qui fut
déroutante
j'étais au chômage mon mari l'était
également
j'étais tombée enceinte et je ne le
savait pas encore mais on allait bientôt
devoir déménager
donc voilà j'avais un petit peu tout ça
dans ma petit jard cassé mais une chose
était sûre à ce moment là j'étais
vraiment convaincu d'une chose je ne
voulais pas choisir entre être maman et
faire carrière entre êtres croyante et
faire carrière et en entrée truies j'ai
fait une entreprise finalement qui soit
tournée vers l'humain en gros j'avais
l'impression qu'on me disait soit qui tu
veux mais pas trop reste bien dans les
cases et je n'avais pas envie finalement
de choisir entre être et faire
je voulais vraiment faire ce que je suis
du coup à partir de ce moment là j'ai
décidé de changer de caméra j'ai décidé
de reprendre mes responsabilités et
vraiment de changer de caméra
l'entrepreneuriat mais a aidé parce que
l'entrepreneuriat m'a permis de me
dépasser et de vouloir le meilleur pour
moi et pour le monde
ma spiritualité également mais à aider
elle m'a permis de vouloir le meilleur
aussi pour moi et pour le monde et c'est
à ce moment là face à moi-même où je me
suis posé une question qui es tu qui
es-tu si tu enlèves toute cette pression
de la société qui es-tu si tu arrêtes de
te mentir
qui es-tu si tu arrêtes de juger un
trait de caractère ou ton apparence qui
es-tu si tu n'a plus peur qu'est-ce que
tu ferais et qu'elles seront quelles
seront les décisions que tu pourrais
prendre et à partir de là c'est devenu
une évidence
tout était parfait
tout était c'est dans ma vie depuis le
berceau jusqu'à maintenant pour que je
sois celle que je dois être tout était
fait pour que je me réaligne à chaque
fois et de toute façon lorsque je
perdais le feu demain on va dire la vie
trouvait bien une façon de me ramener
changement avec une épreuve où ou autre
chose quelqu'un ainsi alors j'ai quelque
chose à vous proposer
pourquoi que vous viviez aujourd'hui
c'est parfait et deux choix s'offrent à
vous
parce que vous aussi vous pouvez décider
de changer de caméra de choisir ce qui
est important pour vous et de regarder
un petit peu ces petits couacs
finalement avec d'autres yeux de les
regarder de l'extérieur est aujourd'hui
quoi qui quoi qu'il se passe
vous avez deux choix premièrement soit
vous plaindre du gouvernement de la
société
je ne sais pas de quoi encore
deuxièmement écouter les signes prendre
les leçons vous adaptez vous dépassez
peu importe le choix que vous allez
faire aujourd'hui c'est parfait tant
qu'il est fait en conscience
bon moi j'ai choisi la deuxième
la deuxième solution est finalement
lorsque je change de caméras tout prend
sa juste place
tout est parfait j'ai compris pourquoi
mon mari il exerçait un métier dans
lequel je ne voyait pratiquement jamais
j'ai compris pourquoi j'avais certains
défauts autant que pour quoi j'avais
certaines qualités j'ai compris que tous
ces moments où j'aurais aimé que ça se
passe autrement j'ai compris qu'ils
étaient juste parfait et j'ai compris
que tous ces moments où j'aurais aimé
être quelqu'un d'autre j'ai compris que
être moi-même était juste la meilleure
solution et c'est ce qui se passe en
fait finalement avec ce parfum tedx
parce que je fais de mon mieux et c'est
ce qui le rend parfait alors le fameux
de l'histoire de tout ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui finalement j'ai 26 ans
j'ai deux entreprises je suis toujours
maman et si je n'avais pas eu tout ce
chemin de vie si je n'avais pas eu tous
ces épreuves je n'en serais pas là où je
suis aujourd'hui et wau juste merci
parce que je n'aurais tellement pas été
moi même à une autre place alors tout ça
finalement c'est parfaitement imparfait
et
tant qu'on vise l'excellence est pas la
perfection au sens où on l'entend
aujourd'hui puisque tout est parfait
alors tout est parfait donc vous aussi
aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous débarrasser
un peu de toutes ces petites croûtes
malsaine qui qui s'est rajoutée au fur à
mesure de vos expériences et avoir une
vie époustouflante selon vos normal donc
aujourd'hui j'ai une question
aujourd'hui si vous changez de caméras
avec tout ce que vous êtes tout ce que
vous avez vos expériences
si vous deviez et pourriez laisser une
trace et un impact sur terre lequel
serait-il et je vous invite à ressentir
au fond de vous cette cause qui émerger
pour laquelle vous avez envie de vous
battre cet enjeu et je peux vous assurer
qu une fois que vous aurez fait émerger
cette cause plus rien ne pourra vous
arrêter alors vraiment aimé vos
blessures chez les scellés c'est la plus
belle chose que vous pouvez avoir et que
vous pouvez offrir au monde
et pour terminer j'aimerais vraiment
encore une fois vous poser cette
question aujourd'hui avec tout ce que
vous êtes tout ce que vous avez
si vous deviez et pourriez laisser un
impact et une trace sur terre quel
serait-il
merci
[Applaudissements]